Wow okay let's draw another diagram okay
now
I said this is a basic form this is a
basic form right what do you think it's
the area under a parabola right so what
I'm gonna do is I'm not gonna have more
rectangles or more trapezium I'm gonna
have more parabolas okay all right so
tell look at this this is how I would
make one parabola out of this okay now
this is what a few not miss okay 300,000
1 2 3 2 subintervals one to one parabola
now if I have been doing trapezoidal
rule and I wanted to be more deeply okay
and this stage I've got two trapezium so
what would you do the next step would be
we'll just have three right so I could
make three traveese you're out of this
and then I'm not anyway okay but I can't
do this is citizens rule why don't cuz I
need three values because have a look at
this you're not okay we're going to my
first problem where you go 1:33 me draw
a promise you're there any like way to
join next problem you stop from this
boundary point overlap whether you get a
1 2 then you're like I need another
value to actually make a parabola right
so this is 1 2 3 4 function days right
since it must work scissors will never
works with even numbers of function
values you always need and
so let's go back this is a person target
one parabola three function guys okay
what's the next one up two travelers
tell me function is five five
so I'm gonna get one two three
functionalities for five
okay and now if you want to imagine you
could draw you to your one traveler
there another one there okay you don't
actually need to picture it you just
need to do that right now we've got more
um we've got more value so I'm gonna
I'll make this the same way we did with
trapezoidal so this is a and this is
between what they call this X 1 X 2 X
okay right now let's just think about
the first parabola which is going to use
these three damage okay it's going to
look exactly the same as this but with a
few different things in yeah so what's a
good point
start with this is on a core area one
well maybe I should walk around what's
it going to be equal to now I'm actually
make good back bother use be my scale to
you see why be mind's eye on suit isn't
gonna cut it where you go from basic
form to more complicated food why not
why doesn't mean to imply exactly right
this x1 is not the people it's not even
close okay now the the numerically wider
problem is because the two corresponds
to two some intervals that's why I have
it right so what would I do here I guess
I'm a divided by four that's what we're
giving my height okay that's um that's H
H and in this case H V is V minus a 1 4
so what generally speaking I guess you'd
say B minus a on
where is what okay so subintervals
function values browser you've got to
make sure you know exactly which ones
which
alright so therefore I'm going to go
back to H as I think it's those rights H
now what are we going to have here first
for the middle and then last okay so the
first one is for of a bit of maths in
this case f of x1 and then one of the
last which is next there's my first
problem so when I do my second one
what's going to be the same what's gonna
be different well the perpendicular
height is the same because the sub
intervals are all the same width right
but now I have a foot first for the
middle and lost the values have changed
right so he's my first now x2 okay and
there's four of the middle one which is
now X okay now just like we trapezoid
rule because we're our privacy we're
getting the same top among if that's -
okay the for spent a lot in some of
these ones here okay so if I were to put
this whole lot together okay what would
you end up with we would say the entire
area is approximately equal to H 1 3 is
comment at the front which by the way if
you want to call it X 1 X 4 that's just
it's just as good because we just have
so many around I think that's actually
doesn't matter how you know if I put
this all together I'm gonna get first
one for this one but these two have left
so now I have two plus for this one
which was the middle of the second
problem and okay so you can see it's the
IG grown but it's growing in a
predictable way okay now this was to
promise what would happen if I had three
now before I write it down
sometimes you see people call this
rather than no rather than say f of B
and F of x3 and so on gets really tired
so because you're writing F all this
over over over again so what we might do
is cold this you know he said x1 x2 x3 I
guess what we cárcel into that is y - y1
what's your blackberry okay
so that's why this is what I was
thinking before that makes this one know
what and this why okay so what if I had
more values along the end and what if I
have three powers for my lost value 5/3
problems he sees right I mean just
imagine if I had you know
beaker y5 y6 and that's enough to draw
my third problem right okay so what
would happen the area it's always going
to have h13 appetizer okay always
but that H is now going to be what's
going to happen here it would have one
of the first how many am I gonna have
the next one it's the middle of one of
the travelers so it's going to be four
right now the next one is the end of one
problem and the beginning of the next
one that's welcome to watch and then it
alternates because this is another
middle and this will be in now in
practice you're really not gonna have to
do more function values to that because
like if we added a fourth parabola
you don't demonstrate any more skill
you're just doing a learner question
right so for that reason yeah this is
all you really need to know however
because there's this pattern here which
ones have a force which ones here for
Tommy is the odd ones right one three
five okay so some formulas will say
you've got the first one you've got four
times all of the odd values right and
then the other ones that even it's how
many do you have of the evens you have
two and then you have okay so you
sometimes see that again it is kind of
dangerous but because you know if you
started ones that is zero then your ones
and even sire exactly backwards right so
people confuse that right sorry I we ran
out of time I'll show you how